welcome everyone to today's conference
Thursday research conference and as
sometimes happens we have people from
the outside although actually really
Homer naymeer not really from the
outside in fact Homer is an affiliate
faculty and amys had some connections
with the ohsu they're going to talk
today on a project that some of you have
probably heard of I find really exciting
the open notes project of patients
having access to their notes so let me
just give very brief introductions not
to take away from their time Amy fellows
is an experienced health care and health
IT professional with 15 years experience
she was the third employee of ocean and
did that took that job right after
finishing her mph at Portland State and
she's been involved with epic at ocean
she's now executive director of this
project we can do better which will hear
about today and aiming to bring the open
notes platform to Oregon Homer dr. Chynn
I suppose I should call him as someone
I've known for about three decades way
back when when we were both the trainees
fellows in informatics and he was at
Stanford I was on the other side of the
country Boston but informatics is a
small field and then of course Homer
came to Portland where he really
provided a lot of leadership around
implementing epic while the this is at
Kaiser Northwest while the larger Kaiser
organization was trying to do something
on its own i always remember his talked
about the billion dollars that kaiser
spent trying to develop an EHR and Homer
was busy actually doing it
here in Portland and of course now all
of Kaiser has chosen to go that route
Homer decided to retire although I see
him working so much I don't know that
he's really retired but I had the
opportunity to attend his retirement
party was that a year or two ago but he
continues to be active both providing
clinical care and then also
participating in this open notes project
so I will turn it over to them and let
me just remind those who are watching
out there in cyberspace that will be
monitoring the twitter feed so if you
have any questions for the speakers just
tweet them to at ohsu informatics or
just hashtag d mice comp DMIC e conf and
we'll be sure to ask them of the
speakers okay well thank you for that
introduction are people able to hear me
on okay great okay so thank you for that
very generous introduction and thank you
for having us here presenting around
open notes now how many of you have
heard of open notes so a show of hands
all about maybe a third to a half okay
that's great and how many of you
actually have a portal into parts of
your own medical record right now
through some kind of might right thing
okay so about half of you that's really
great and then how many of you have
heard about an organization called we
can do better okay so they're a casa
mattering and this is an opportunity to
talk to you also about we can do better
which was originally formed as the
Archimedes movement with dr. Kitzhaber
with john Kitzhaber our governor and
eventually they decided to maybe change
the name to something that was more
meaningful than our communities movement
and the idea is that it empowers
citizens to improve health care from a
grassroots level and Amy will talk a
little bit more about it in terms of the
open notes consortium there are a number
of sponsors and organizations that are
involved so they can be a health
Foundation has given us a grant to do
this work the Robert Wood Johnson is
involved also at funding the National a
we can do better open notes yeah sorry
the National open notes effort and we're
getting some of our funding from them
and then Consumer Reports is helping to
push open notes and make it better known
and then there's the national open notes
movement that we will talk a little bit
about as well so with open notes the
basic idea is improved medical record
transparency so patients are invited to
review the doctor's visit notes to
secure patient portals and this is one
of the things you know there's some
debate as to the benefits of electronic
health records but if you think about
open notes this is one of the benefits
and one of the things that could not be
done without the advent of electronic
health records so with electronic health
records it enables certain things and
one of the things that it enables is
increased patient transparency how many
of you have tried to look at your
medical record or go to release of
information to look at your medical
record oh so there there a few that's
great so HIPAA allows you and says yes
you do have access to your medical
record but as you know for those of you
that have accessed it and for those of
you that haven't it is often quite
difficult to get access you have to make
an appointment with release of
information go down there and then
review your medical records and then if
you want to make a copy of it sometimes
they will charge you for it and so the
idea with open notes is to give you
access relatively immediately and easily
through the internet so the way it works
is each patient is notified
automatically by a secure email that
their note that the doctor wrote in the
electronic medical record is available
and reminded to review it before their
next scheduled visit so with that we
have
a little video that we are going to play
if I can get this to work
last year when I was pregnant I had gone
to see my primary care for a checkup and
everything thank goodness was fine but
she did notice a mole on my back that
she had asked me to follow up with the
dermatologist but being pregnant had
forgotten all about it I remember a few
weeks later there was something nagging
at me and then I was reading through my
notes and I saw the notation that said
referred to follow up with dermatologist
so I did I immediately went to the
dermatologist and she felt that it
needed to be removed I was so incredibly
relieved primarily and I felt this sense
of safety as well because I actually had
a hand in what was going on with my own
health care what this patient
exemplifies for me is what we've been
hoping to do for the last 30 years
really find mechanisms to get patients
much more actively involved in their
care the open note study was a one-year
experiment in which primary care doctors
invited their patients to read their
visit notes online after the visit what
we're doing now is reporting on what we
learned both from surveys and anecdotes
of patients of doctors and also by
measuring email traffic when I was asked
to join open notes I got to say I had a
lot of ambivalence initially I didn't
know how much extra work that would
represent I already feel busy at times
stress so I wasn't sure how it would all
work out I kind of braced for it being a
big deal and it wasn't much of a big
deal doctors told us they didn't notice
more questions or emails or phone calls
from patients contrary to the fears of
many of the doctors very few patients
were worried or confused by this on the
other hand ninety percent of them read
their notes far more than we expected
and when we asked the patients what they
got out of the notes it was really
pretty amazing over eighty percent of
patients said things like they
understood their care better they
remembered their plan of care better
they felt more in control of their care
and most excitingly at all to this
doctor two out of three patients who are
on medicines said they're taking their
medicines better having it written down
it's almost like there's another person
telling you to take your meds let's go
to listen to your arteries here there's
no question in my mind that those people
who became engaged in the program became
more engaged in their own healthcare
they came better prepared for their
visits they ask better questions they
knew their medications and their doses
when they came in I feel like I know my
medical life better because of the open
notes the findings of this study
suggests that this kind of transparency
is here to stay at the end of the study
we gave doctors the option to
discontinue open notes and not one of
them did and ninety-nine percent of the
patients wanted open notes to continue
eighty-five percent of them said that
they would consider the availability of
open notes in choosing a provider in the
future for me to be able to look back on
notes and make sure that the doctor did
see everything that I wanted her to see
or did record everything I wanted him or
her to record in a way that I find
suitable for me as a patient hands down
I would never go back to not having that
access and availability I do open notes
as a new medicine it's designed to help
most people and I think it does it has
contraindications for some but overall I
think the benefits will way outweigh the
costs and we'll move care forward in
fact I really hope that this kind of
transparency will become the standard of
care in this country and around the
world in the next very few years
okay great so that was a little video
and they're actually probably like six
or seven videos they're at the open
notes our website if folks are
interested in working at some of the
other videos but it is very powerful
when you talk to the people that are
involved open notes was a research and
demonstration project in 2010 involving
more than 100 primary care providers and
they deliberately picked three different
locations one was an urban location and
other in rural Pennsylvania and then one
was with the medically indigent
medically underserved in Seattle at
Harborview and interestingly enough the
results from all three locations were
relatively the same it's supported
primarily by the Robert Wood Johnson
Foundation in also cambia for our local
work and when they did the study they
had three overall questions one was does
open notes help patients become more
engaged in their care his open notes the
straw that breaks the doctors back you
know when Robert wah was here he's the
president of the AMA and he was talking
about things that are frustrating for
clinicians I forget what that number was
but significant proportion of physicians
felt that electronic health records was
an extra burden added to the work and
the question is open notes the straw
that breaks the doctors back in terms of
additional work and then after living
with this transparency to patients and
doctors want to continue so we'll get
back to these questions at the end of
the study and try to answer them reports
from the patients among patients with
with notes eighty-two percent of
patients open at least one of their
notes and it isn't without side effects
so one to eight percent of patients
across the three sites reported that the
notes caused confusion where your
offense those are the things that we
always worry about when patients are
looking at what the physician has
written down in a way that may not be
necessarily geared to to patients and
then interestingly enough
to forty-two percent shared notes with
others which was really a surprise but
in the advent of all these sites like
Facebook it probably isn't too much of a
surprise you know some people who take
notes and say this is what the doctors
saying about me or if they didn't
understand other note they might cut and
paste it and forward it to a family
member and say here's what the doctor
says with what do you think this really
means but in terms of the benefits the
reports from patients were seventy
percent reported taking better care of
themselves eighty percent better
understanding with their medical
conditions eighty percent remembering
the plan for their care better eighty
percent better prepared for visits more
in control of their care and doing
better with taking my medications as
prescribed so the interesting thing is
that if this was like a drug a pharmacy
medication and they produce this drug i
mean the the pharmacy companies would
really be trying to market the hell out
of this to to get patients you know if
there's an intervention that has this
much of a positive effect you would
think that people would be clamoring to
get this medication but these are the
effects of this intervention before and
after the study was started they asked
physicians what they felt the impact
would be on their workflow twenty-four
percent felt that their visits would be
significantly longer and after the
intervention they asked the physicians
again and only two percent felt their
visits were significantly longer now
interestingly enough they didn't ask the
question because they didn't think this
would ever happen and one of the things
that I posed to the people that did the
study was if you asked the question
whether visits were significantly
shorter because it's potentially
possible that if patients are reading
their notes and are engaged in their
care you know the visits might be
shorter because it will have fewer
questions because they've been able to
read their physicians note and so that's
one of the questions that they didn't
ask but I think there's a real
possibility that the visits could be
significantly shorter more time
addressing patient questions outside of
the visits forty two percent of the
clinicians felt that they would
experience that and at the end of the
study only three percent and the
question again is is it actually making
the positions life a little easier as
opposed to more difficult and then more
time writing editing and dictating notes
39-percent expected that they would be
spending more time and after the
intervention only eleven percent said
they were it's clear that some of the
physicians are changing the way they
write their notes and sort of subtle
ways you know things like patient
complains of you know sometimes it's a
little sensitive when the patients as
well you know I'm really wasn't
complaining and so there's some of those
things that subtle changes that that
might have been made in the visits and
then comport Lee compared to the year
preceding the intervention you know in
many of these systems you're able to
message the physician and the question
was were they getting more messages
around their their notes where they
getting more things that they had to
deal with outside of the visit and it's
clear that they were not and the bottom
line is for pcps when offered the option
of turning off open notes not one doctor
asked to do so now i would say that
we're probably a small percentage of
doctors said that ah i'm not so sure
this is a good idea but when they were
given the option at the end of the study
to say okay you know we can turn off
open notes not one of the doctors opted
to actually turn it off and then for
patients after one year ninety-nine
percent in all three locations wanted to
continue to be able to see their health
now interestingly enough you know not
all of those patients were actually
accessing the note you know between
eighty and ninety percent of patients
actually access the note but ninety-nine
percent of them said they wanted this
continued to continue and I suppose this
is like voting you know even if you
don't vote you want the right to be able
to vote and so even those that did not
necessarily access their notes said hey
you know I want to have the capability
to access the note so going back to the
three overall questions there's
notes help patients become more engaged
in their care yes it's clear that it
does I mean it's not without you know a
few side effects but overall the
predominant sense is that there is very
significant benefit to doing this is
open notes the straw that breaks the
doctors back no and in fact potentially
it could make the life of the position
actually a little easier to get the
patient more engaged in understanding of
what's going on and then after living
with a fancy to virtually under percent
so the answer to this these questions is
overwhelmingly positive and then for the
institutions all three sites decided to
expand open notes and there are other
organizations that have implemented the
open notes concept MD Anderson Cancer
Center actually predates the open notes
movement the Mayo Clinic the VA has been
doing this as you probably heard from
Susan Boyd's the VA here did this
starting I think in like 2001 and the
rest of the VA has adopted this since
the beginning of 2013 and so as a
veteran you can access actually your
entire medical record not just the note
that your doctor put in and then Group
Health has done a pilot and Cleveland
Clinic is moved forward and there are
more coming so our sense is that
eventually this may be a new standard of
care who is sharing notes these are all
the organizations that are sharing notes
I think you've heard about most of them
the interesting thing is that with the
Northwest consortium work a lot of these
organizations are now in the northwest
so we are the part of the country that
has the most organizations that have
climbed on board and our implementing
open notes so that's just a measure of
how successful this approach has been
again HIPAA says you have access to your
medical record but as you know it's not
easy to access your medical record and
so this
makes it easy for you to Texas your
medical record relatively easily and
quickly and for those of you that are
accessing how many of you are accessing
your chart through through like my chart
through the epic system okay so with the
epic system you know they already have
all that functionality it's just a
matter of opening the note to the my
chart functionality and so for certain
vendors it is not very difficult to do
this and the benefits are very
significant this just gives you a view
of the open notes website that you can
go to they've developed a toolkit so if
you're an organization that wants to
implement open notes there are all sorts
of tools their presentations that you
can use to show your staff and the
physicians and then videos as I
mentioned that are accessible for those
of you that are interested and so with
that I'm going to turn it over to my
partner in crime specifically about
can you hear me for the string okay so
the idea of the Northwest open notes
consortium started in February 2013 at
weekend abettors annual conference and
like Homer said we can do better is
really a civic engagement organization
helping educate the public about how to
have a voice in improving the health
system Health Transformation having an
impact in health policy and our main
role is as a convener and our kind of
signature event is our annual conference
that we have each year so in 2013 do how
many of you have heard of John Santa
who's now Consumer Reports used to live
in Oregon now back in Oregon so he came
and spoke at our februari 2013
conference and kind of his typical
consumer reports feel with comparing
hospital systems and such but uh quality
metrics but he talked about two things
that at the time were kind of just up
and coming one was open notes and the
other was choosing wisely the feedback
from our evaluations of that year's
conference was people were really
interested in this open notes thing so
from that feedback are weak and abettors
board decided we want to do something
about that we want to bring it to Oregon
so in june 2013 Liz Baxter who's the
previous executive director and john
santa convened a group of Oregon's
health systems consumer groups and
policy makers up at the Arboretum and we
brought out Tom and Jane that you saw in
the video and basically introduced this
concept of open notes to Oregon at that
meeting that's kind of when we roped
homer in because he stood up and said
this is a great idea he recently retired
and and the at that meeting several of
the system said you know this is
something that they thought they would
be interested in definitely Kaiser kind
it was the one that said you know we've
been on my chart for quite a while and I
think we're ready to do something like
this so we then not yet funded but took
that idea in in September 2013 we
invited back just the system folks and
mainly the sea mio
type people and had this gathering and
said are you interested in this idea of
not only doing open notes but doing it
together as a community and so most of
the big systems from the Portland metro
area were there Susan woods was involved
so it was nice to have some kind of a a
cheerleader that said we've done this
and it was okay so she had been involved
in that early formation and from that
we've been meeting probably bimonthly
and it has continued to evolve so these
are the organizations that are currently
participating in the consortium and by
participating and being a consortium
member really you're saying at some
point soon we want to do this open notes
thing whether it's 2014 or 2015 but in
the near future we want to do this so
these are the organizations and I love
them are portland metro but a lot of
them also are a multi-state or in other
parts of the state and then salem health
and Samaritan health are the ones that
are kind of a little bit further and
we're working on expanding south and
east so thoroughly adopters as Homer
said the Portland VA who had been on
previously and especially here in the
Portland area Kaiser Northwest from that
September meeting to ape just from that
September to April timeframe decided
that they weren't going to just do it
like a little pilot at one clinic with
one provider but they were really going
to do it and they opened up their notes
to all five hundred thousand patients at
once so all the Northwest at once so
that's Salem and that's Vancouver and
the whole system so that that inspired a
little bit of what we're calling Co
opposition between the other systems and
you know they're like oh we better you
better do this and step it up so ocean
has turned on its system it would be
great to continue to work on getting the
ocean organizations on my chart so that
they can do this they they have so
they've set it up so doctors or
organizations can opt in and a couple of
them have ohsu family practice patience
have access since May this summer the
Portland clinic and the Vancouver clinic
opened their notes and each one as
organizations has done things slightly
differently and part of what we do at
the consortium is they share how they've
done that so for example Kaiser with
their my chart doesn't give adolescence
of access to my chart is it 13 to 17 so
they just no longer have access and the
parent doesn't have access either
measure so there's no access in that
period and that's just their policy and
how they've done that well the Vancouver
clinic decided that they wanted to try
doing open notes for the adolescent the
adolescent chooses whether or not they
proxy the parents so that'll be
something that we talked about and kind
of see so it's kind of fun that there's
all these little mini experiments
happening um so legacy we found out has
12 providers that have their kind of
doing a opt-in type of thing so like
Kaiser there was there was no opt-out
except for there is a click box that per
visit if there's a sensitive note they
can select a note not to be in but
you'll see later very few people are
doing that PeaceHealth as of two weeks
ago their vancouver site opened up their
notes and then they're planning on
moving forward with their other sites
providence is planning 2015 salem health
and 2015 and then samaritan health
started just with their imaging reports
so again it's kind of a different model
you know they plan to move forward but
they decided will pilot with imaging
reports so some of the early information
that we got from Kaiser since they
really did it full force was that the
traffic to their portal was up four
hundred percent after they opened up the
notes to that review visit section of
the portal that their doctors email
traffic was flat so people weren't doing
you know my chart through kp.org that
didn't increase the there were very rare
concerns from patients about their care
that only even though they gave them
that option that they could select note
by note to hide it only one quarter of
one percent of the notes for hidden and
it sounded like most of those were in
dietary where they're working with
people with eating disorders where there
might be a concern of the person
obsessing about looking at their weight
mental health providers at this point
have been excluded and like I said a lad
sins have been excluded and they now
have 7,000 notes per day available to
their patients and if any of you have
got have any of you gone to Kaiser since
April where you get a little email that
says you may now view your note you
click on it and it takes you immediately
there
no not well I think if it's happening
and try I think if this happening in
primary care it's it's available if it's
having a primary care unless the
provider selected it not to but if it's
specifically like psychiatric however
the VA from the beginning or known of
his from the beginning that the VA has
had their psych notes open and really
didn't have any issues from that and
that's probably a population that has a
loan we have a lot of use for the
segment um so these are some anecdotal
things from patients from the patient
advisory council which are kind of fun
yeah I'll just let you read this for a
minute that yeah putting the note up on
their refrigerator I like and that my
doctor now now knows that i really don't
run every day
so these are just some anecdotes of the
patients who got to experience that
early on shavers so one of the things as
homer and i are out sharing about open
notes home were presented at acumen chua
IPA consortium and i think that the
consortium is focused on a shared
immunization portal or something but
there were a variety of different
organizations that were on different
emrs there and so this just kind of
opened up our eyes that if we want to
move beyond the big systems that are on
epic which were you know kind of more of
a slam dunk than we had expected that we
have a little bit more of a challenge
because there's all these different
systems with different portals the
portal and the EHR might not be the same
company and trying to figure out that
landscape plus the fact that in a
smaller practice they're going to need a
little bit more support potentially and
selling this and making it happen so
these are kind of the top within that IP
a consortium of the top EHR so there's
Athena eClinicalWorks Amazing Charts
practice Fusion Cerner centricity might
arid and so on and then this is
statewide we got this information from
the opposite health IT which is I think
the surveys from looks like twenty
eleven to twenty thirteen so these are
kind of the top vendors statewide so
we're starting to look at our strategy
of how do we work with those smaller
organizations and actively looking for
funding to support that because we know
it's going to take a little bit more
hands-on to make that happen
so most of the same players that you saw
on the other screen and the point the
survey was done epic was forty-four
percent and then this is looking at the
portals patient portal feature and some
ratings of that so just again helping us
understand kind of what is the landscape
this one this is from the physicians it
looks the medscape survey position
so so in summary open notes is a
national initiative that's working to
give patients access to their visit
notes there's proven benefits that Homer
talked about the patient engagement the
minimal physician impact and the cost
benefit and then the Northwest open
notes consortium we were the first the
open notes movement nationally would
have has been working with individual
organizations that we were the first to
do it as a community and to try to pull
people together and move forward
together and we're continuing to add
groups hummer and I presented at hims
and we had a couple of new groups when
luckily from Bend and others that are
looking to come on and then this is just
freaking you betters website and if you
haven't checked this out check us out
usually there's a lot of stuff in our
blog health policy related stuff allies
for healthier Oregon is another one of
our programs and it's a group of patient
advocate and other nonprofits that come
together to share their kind of their
legislative agendas so that they they
don't Lobby per se as a group but they
show the legislative agendas with each
other so that when they do go to lobby
individually in Salem there at least
more in sync and closer together it was
something that that we can better saw a
need for a few years ago and then we
support the choosing the oma zephyr with
choosing wisely as well
yeah so first of all let me remind
people when they talk to press the
button down so it gets recorded and the
people who are listening through
streaming can hear it my question is I
am Tom yako gave a presentation to the
Department of Medicine here about a year
ago and I was under the impression that
the physicians actively had to put some
kind of tag in their notes to get it to
go into open notes but it sounds like in
at least the ones you describing that
that's not the case I think that a year
ago people weren't quite sure how they
were going to do it and when we had that
jun 2013 meeting we actually I think
they were on the phone nuttin yeah we
did have one person person someone Judy
sent someone from epic out to support
that because Tom and Jane had just prior
to that kind of started working with her
about open notes and as epic going to
support it so so we've continued and
this consortium has helped the
consortium actually presented at this
year's ugm to help epic understand how
to make it easier and easier but Kaiser
found a way to do it with this checkbox
that makes it a little bit easier if
you're opting in and I'm not sure I
don't remember how ohsu ended up setting
it up I think it I think they did it the
same way and partially you know it
depends on the version that you're on
and and their different ways to set up
set it up so I think initially we
thought you would have to put in a smart
text that would then open a nota Iran
with it wither 2012 but then when you
went to the 2014 then you could default
it and you can default it at the
individual clinician level or at the
institutional level department level and
the interesting thing is in talking with
epic you know the epic developers were
really pushing the people that were at
that session saying maybe we should
default this open notes as a inherent
function in my chart and then the
institutions would have to actively say
no we're not going to do it and enter
and configure the system to not not do
this and so you know there was a lot of
discussion is is the world is the epic
world ready to embrace
this and make this the default and I
think the decision was no it's a it's a
little bit too early but it's
interesting yeah the developers were
pushing the folks for that we're at that
meeting first I apologize for not
reading your slide that had my answer
right there question laboratory ins are
worried about the new regulation to give
direct results to patients physicians
are worried that it'll go out without
context before they can get their notes
to them my question to you is do you
think lab results should go out by
themselves or should they be in the
context of the physicians notes through
open notes no you know Mike yeah my
sense is you know one of the questions
what's the timing around that so many
organizations default deceptive labs to
go out right away you know cholesterol
levels for instance go out right away
and then they default the bulk of
everything else if it's normal to go out
right away if it's abnormal at least
what Kaiser Permanente does is it says
okay we're going to give the physician
five days to review and then release and
if they don't review and release within
five days than at five days they
automatically get released and that has
resolved basically almost a hundred
percent of the patient you know issues
and also physician issues and so that's
the balance that they found on in terms
of the meaningful use regulations are
these regulations i'm not sure if
there's a time limitation where they say
immediate release my sense is that they
don't have that immediate release
there's right that's right yes that
that's right the good news about Kaiser
Permanente is we are the lab so it's all
one organization
yeah so I have two questions and I'm
sorry I got here late so you may have
you know answered it early on but it's
there at a specific app that you can
download for you know android
smartphones or anything like that for
the notes and then so so open notes is
not a technology it's just the concept
that patients should have accessed their
notes so whatever so like my chart has
an app and my chart is the portal that
most of these systems are using for
patients to access their notes so the
idea of open notes is just really the
concept patients should have easy access
to the notes in whatever portal they're
using an app for my chart which which
there is then what they do is they take
the note and the appended to the part
that has the after visit summary which
is already available more epic users
it's been very easy to just append the
note itself to the apt visit something
so you go to that section and and the
notice there so it's been exactly it's
the same yeah
a little bit of both but but mainly
right now is in order to talk to all
those vendors and gear up to engage the
vendors as well as the organizations
around open notes we have very limited
funding so we would need funding for
instance to possibly hire folks to
engage and do that or to go to the ins
the meetings and set up meetings with
all those vendors it's clear that the
vendors need to be involved because most
of this functionality would need to be
developed by the vendor you know most of
the organizations are small enough that
it would be very difficult for them to
independently notice we have not but I
mean no I yeah you know I I think one of
the key questions that remains
unanswered is outcomes are they
different a utilization you know are
people that are able to access open
notes less likely to be seen in the
emergency room for instance would be
hospitalized we don't know that answer
but clearly if there are changes in
utilization and improved outcomes then
it would be a win-win all around sent
answer your question at this point yet
so you know it's pretty obvious the open
notes transparency is the way to go but
one of the lessons learned to avoid that
one to eight percent adverse effect rate
I don't know that you can completely
avoid it I don't know that you can avoid
how somebody might respond I mean there
are some lessons like at our last
meeting Kaiser was talking about
developing a crosswalk when Kaiser did
it especially since they did so big all
at one time they advised their providers
not to change how they normally did
chart notes to be aware that their
patients are seeing it so if they were
using the abbreviation sob they might
want to spell it out or use the dot
phrase that was spelled out for them so
things like that but but like Homer
started with like the complains of which
is how doctors are trained they're
starting to develop crosswalks just with
simple words like that and I think
what's really interesting and I don't
know who will ever fund this study or
how it would happen but that as this
kind of happens and becomes the new
standard of care will it change how
providers chart and will that ever cycle
back to how providers are trained as
there's more and more transparency
because the way that they chart is the
way that they were you know trained to
think as far as complains of and those
kind of things yeah just one quick
comment I noticed that you've got 19,000
patients with the actual number reported
and over 100 positions which means
you're getting a very small percentage
of the panel yeah that was the original
study so that was the original contained
study that they did in out of Beth
Israel what was the selection criteria
for that hundred and ninety patients per
provider yeah you know interestingly
enough when they originally did the
study they solicited from clinicians so
they asked clinicians whether they would
be interested in they took the physician
that were willing to go ahead and open
up their panel and then they opened it
up to their panel of patients so I don't
know that the patients were selected the
positions were selected initially so
it's it's not an unbiased selection of
physicians but the response was so
positive that they were able to move it
move it forward the estimate now is that
there I think the latest estimate is 3.7
million patients are able to ask
us have the functionality to be able to
access their physicians know so things
are ramping up very very quickly yeah
and I would just add that I think that
there is some self selection because
some of the late adopters it seems our
patient's with ocean or places that were
there's more complex patients those
providers are a little bit have been a
little bit slower to adopt my chart for
one but I think are a little bit more
hesitant at least when I've had
one-on-one conversations people that
have dual diagnosis patients and other
things are a little bit more hesitant to
go this route but again like the VA who
has a lot of complex patients opened up
even their psych notes and didn't have
any major adverse effects
there other questions what kind of open
notes do other countries have I know
that Tom and GN r are doing
international speaking so I don't know
if they're being asked to four countries
that are wanting to but I don't I don't
know it's a good question
I know it's in certain countries and
actually in the military in the old days
if you're in the in the DoD they used to
give you your chart so you know you'd
bring your chart in and they would
document in it they would so when I was
more actively practicing I used to have
patients that would come in from the
military and they would have their chart
with him and then I know in China they
when when I was visiting many years ago
that's what patients would do they would
be the people that would carry their
chart the physician would write a note
into their chart and then give it to
them so to a certain extent you know in
the old days before the advent of
electronic health records things were
were fairly open I know in other
countries also they're much more open
about giving patients access to their
medical record because the patient is
paying for for instance the radiology
test and so the radiology test really
belongs to the patient and goes to the
patient there isn't this issue with
insurance and and that kind of thing to
sort of confounding so I my sense is
that at least in some of the other
countries the medical record is much
more open than it traditionally has been
in the US does the open Newt project
have plans to promote patient
contributed data into patient portals
you know that that is one of the big
things that Tom and Jen who are at Beth
Israel are pushing for next is a
combined chart that the patient and the
physician work together to contribute to
and so that's one of their next steps
that they're looking at
for patients who aren't interested in
being involved per se are they allowed
to give their access to a family member
they would have to with the patient
portal or that my chart type application
they would have to make a family member
of proxy at that level and so we have we
have all these great ideas of things we
want to do that we're looking for
funding one is working with smaller
practices and doing that whole vendor
strategy which would be necessary to
work with smaller practices that other
is really because this kind of blew up
from our approach working with the
health systems through the CM iOS really
doing a consumer patient level education
to help have a push from the consumer
side so we started talking with AARP
about their caregivers campaign and kind
of figuring out where there might be
some synergy between their caregiver
campaign and open notes and you know
people assigning caregivers or family
members as processed so one of the
things that I think has with my chart is
the ability to give proxy access so
patients can give proxy access or if
you're the guardian of somebody who's
elderly and and has Alzheimer's for
instance you might be given proxy access
and one of the very active discussions
with epic is well what do you do with
open notes and so the question is if you
give somebody proxy access should you
give them proxy access to everything or
can you say okay proxy access except for
the physicians note or you get the
physicians don't unless the person
deliberately says oh for this visit you
know my proxy does not have access to
the note so there's you know that's all
actively under discussion
actually some kind of you know hit the
issue or anything with the idea of notes
I mean is are they just discussing that
because of their own personal belief
system or are there any kind of security
issues that they're afraid of well I
think I mean with HIPAA the patient can
decide who they want to give access to
so the question is do you set up
functionality in the portal or something
like my chart where the patient can
decide when and how the person they
assigned as their proxy gets access and
so that would be customization that
would like Eric would have to do to give
that patient level control which of
course you all know adds complexity when
you get to that some of the other areas
where a provider likely would hide the
know is if there's anything with
domestic violence because even if the
husband or whatever wasn't necessarily
the proxy they might you know intimidate
the person to make them look at the note
or something so that's another area
where providers typically will probably
hide a note there's anything like that
that answer your question
right the default now is to give them
access so the proxy has access to
everything the individual patient has
accessed but the you know the question
in the room and some folks said well I
might want my proxy to access everything
but there might be a specific visit you
know that I don't want them to access or
you know some people were thinking well
you know for some proxies yeah
everything but for other proxies you
know maybe that's too sensitive you know
the note itself so should the system
have capability for the individual to
say okay proxy access except for these
parts of the medical record and that's
still up for discussion because every
additional functionality do you add you
know adds complexity and then there's
confusion about exactly you know what
exists and what doesn't so that's an
area I would say that's under active
discussion but there's nothing around
HIPAA regulation that says one way or
the other
does HIPAA normalized laws across states
or is there still a variation like in
the whole teenage birth control where
they can organization like Kaiser that
serves patients in multiple states may
have to configure the system different
there are differences in state so I
think and and they're different in
differences in age ranges so when I was
looking at this I remember in Washington
it was like 13 to 17 but in Oregon it
was like 12 to 17 and so they you know
then all the singing up to accommodate
for all the all these differences and so
my sense is that there are differences
in states i you know i'm no longer
completely knowledgeable about exactly
what's going on but bill maybe you've
got was just going to say actually
there's a course that covers that topic
but the hip is a floor and so states can
you know ken can basically raised the
bar but you know actually I don't what
this might be splitting hairs I actually
don't know that it's HIPAA per se that
sets the rules about patient access to
their medical records because didn't
that actually proceed HIPAA or did or
was HIPAA again this might be splitting
hairs and in on the different states I
mean I know there's a couple of us that
have er currently work it out in the
room that was something that they don't
look a lot especially around mental
health there's a lot of mental health
STDs and teens are kind of the hot
things where their states ratchet down
or up and yeah test results so yeah so
now that you know that like they're in
18 or 19 or however main states
okay well thank you very much